bonsoir à tous ravis de vous retrouver à
la une de ça vous regarde ce soir le
scandale des violences sexuelles dans le
sport la parole des patineuses s'est
libéré l'omerta s'est brisé et après
quelles conséquences auront tous ces
témoignages at-on vraiment pris le
problème à bras le corps et dans les
clubs dans les fédérations nos enfants
sont ils vraiment aux protégés on en
parle ce soir dans notre grand débat
avec notamment adrien taquet le
secrétaire d'état à la protection de
l'enfance ne vous demandez plus si le
racisme anti-asiatique existe le court
navires us a fini par montrer que
c'était une maladie cette crise
sanitaire a rouvert la boîte de pandore
partout dans le monde les réseaux
sociaux déborde d' insulte comment
lutter contre c'est la question du soir
et puis notre grand témoin ce soir est
un amoureux de la langue française et
des hommes politiques
d'autres fois ce qu'ils avaient de la
grandeur de la tenue de la pudeur et de
la hauteur pas étonnant qu'il est écrit
un dictionnaire amoureux du général de
gaulle qui sort aujourd'hui
denis tillinac est avec nous ce soir
voilà vous savez tout est parti acheter
accès vers n'oubliez pas on va
[Musique]
et bienvenue à vous chers
téléspectateurs merci d'avoir choisi lcp
nos invités en plateau ce soir denis
tillinac bonsoir je vous remercie d'être
notre grand témoin vous êtes écrivain
prolixe cinquantaine de titres
journalistes éditeurs et vous êtes un
nostalgique assumez vous avez bien le
mot des hommes politiques d'antan de ce
monde d'hier qui a disparaît peu à peu
vous publiez un nouveau dictionnaire
amoureux chez plon cette fois c'est au
général de gaulle que vous faites une
belle déclaration d'amour livre que vous
dédié à votre père on en parlera tout à
l'heure dans cette émission mais d'abord
l'actualité ça fait la une depuis
quelques jours ce sont ces scandales
sexuels qui secoue le monde du sport on
en parle avec vous adrien taquet bonsoir
et merci d'avoir accepté notre
invitation vous êtes secrétaire d'état à
la protection de l'enfance que doit
faire l'état pour garantir aux familles
et bien que elles peuvent mettre leur
enfant sécurité dans les clubs dans les
fédérations vous nous le dira et simon
latournerie bonsoir merci d'être là vous
êtes ancien joueur de rugby
professionnel
aujourd'hui entraîneur c'est bien ça
entraîneur g le diplôme effectivement
pour le faire en tous les cas vous êtes
membre d'une association colosse aux
pieds d'argile qui luttent contre la
pédocriminalité dans le sport
association qui je le dit d'entrée de
jeu n'a pas travaillé avec didier
gailhaguet le patron de la fédération
des sports de glace contrairement à ce
qu'il a affirmé dans sa conférence de
presse
enfin vandry la noce bonsoir merci
d'être là vous êtes journaliste
réalisateur en quête disclose que dont
vous êtes l'auteur qui a été diffusé sur
france 2 dans l'émission envoyé spécial
enquête sur l'omerta sur la pédophilie
dans le sport merci à tous les cadres de
participer à ce débat en direct je vous
donne la parole dans un instant celui
qui nous plante le décor à sa manière
comme tous les soirs cette fois c'est ce
qui se passe dans le monde du sport si
j'ai bien compris c'est signé stéphane
blakowski tout de suite
[Musique]
bonsoir stéphane si j'ai bien compris ce
soir si j'ai bien compris
myriam finalement semblerait que
l'église catholique ne soit pas la seule
institution touchés par des affaires de
pédophilie
on avait beaucoup de d'affaires de
prêtres pédophiles à la une des journaux
on était très concentré sur la
pédophilie dans l'église et puis
peut-être que on a oublié qu'aujourd'hui
finalement il ya quand même beaucoup
plus d'enfants qui sont inscrits dans
des clubs des associations sportives
plutôt que d'enfants écrit le catéchiste
rue catéchisme donc dans l'église
souvent la gare qui a opposé de la loi
du silence quand on l'accusait ben ça
s'est un peu dissipée ça il ya eu
beaucoup de témoignages et les enquêtes
journalistiques surtout il ya eu des
procès donc la parole s'est libérée
alors que dans le monde sportif
on en est pas encore là et bien une
sorte de loi du silence d'ailleurs la
ministre
roxana maracineanu avait d'abord tiré
signalent leur n'y a même plus d'un an
c'était en novembre 2018 et lisait à rtl
bon j'ai pas mes textes récemment mais
vous verrez ces propos que oui à une
amortie sur les violences sexuelles dans
le sport comment l expliquer cette
omerta alors dans le monde du patinage
en fait c'est pas à proprement parler
une omerta fin je vous explique dire que
avant que sarah abitbol publie son livre
pour révéler qu'elle avait été violée
parce que l'entraîneur beaucoup de monde
dans le monde du patinage français se
doutait que vous savez plus exactement
que gilles meyer sont beyer pendant son
entraîneur avait des relations
inappropriées avec ses élèves mais
explique nathalie péchalat donc une
championne de cette époque c'est qu'en
fait c'est pas vraiment une omerta au
sens de représailles et qui les
empêchait de parler surtout qu'il
n'avait pas du tout conscience de la
gravité des faits dont on écoute sa
version sur un gramme ce qui me surprend
le plus c'est qu'on a eu on a tous
entendu des petites phrases types
il a frappé à la chambre d'une fille à
une heure du matin et lui envoyer un
texto un peu chaud mais encore une fois
on prenait ça avec évidemment trop de
légèreté mais on pensait que c'était
c'est un cas isolé qui avait pas eu de
suite non évidemment le livre de sarah
abitbol lui a ouvert les yeux et donc
aujourd'hui nathalie nathalie péchalat
elle a un petit peu mauvaise conscience
en fait ne pas avoir bien mesurer la
gravité des faits s'en explique mais oui
je suis tombé de haut est quelque part
une petite voix dans ma tête me disait
souviens toi ce que tu as entendu c'est
pas forcément
voilà c'était pas forcément ce que ce
que je pensais c'est en fait c'est très
grave c'est très grave et aujourd'hui on
est là pour réparer sa nana c'est très
grave et la prise de conscience elle est
bien là aujourd'hui n'a d'ailleurs
nathalie péchalat s'est engagé à la
tribune qui étaient publics parisiens 54
sportifs l'ont signée dont teddy riner
notre super champion donc oui on la voit
paraître il décide et il est temps de
donner de la voix donc de briser le mur
du silence mais si à tant de champions
qu'ils ont signés c'est évidemment il
n'ya pas que le patinage dont on parle
qui est touchée par la violence sexuelle
d'ailleurs c'était un des arguments de
didier gailhaguet pour se défendre
plutôt que d'assumer sa part de
responsabilité mais égard par mois il ya
aussi d autres en écoute je sais aussi
que nous ne sommes pas les seuls puisque
28 sports ont été concernés l'an passé
par 77 à faire sur des mineurs de moins
de 15 ans voilà alors face à l'étendue
du problème que propose le gouvernement
alors vous avez raison quand il ya un
problème le ministre doit prendre des
mesures évidemment bon et pas de mesures
qu'il va faire disparaître d'un coup les
violences sexuelles et non mais le
gouvernement rassurez vous a quand même
pris des mesures notamment il souhaite
que l'on puisse vérifier que dans les
bénévoles dans les clubs de sport soit
pas sur un fichier les agresseurs
sexuels qui existent donc à 84 mille
noms sur ce fichier
et puis il est déjà utilisé dans
l'éducation nationale par exemple
s'assure que les profs ne figure pas
n'est pas à passer un casier
d'agresseurs sexuels
mais est-ce que c'est suffisant mais
même là ce n'est pas sûr en fait parce
qu'il faut que le fichier soit un jour
faut que les gens parlent est ce que tu
as remarqué à la ministre c'est que dans
le cas de l'entraîneur de sarah bitbol
jb hier on aurait consulté les fiches et
on a redit mais pas de problèmes on les
écoute aujourd'hui ce monsieur n'avait
rien dans son casier judiciaire
rien donc il faut que les gens qui ont
subi des choses connues des choses
petites filles petit garçon grande fille
grandes gares son grand garçon qui
viennent témoigner pour qu'on ait des
éléments
elles vont pouvoir accumuler tous ces
gens mais ce qui passera devant le juge
alors j'ai un copain il me dit souvent
que tu sais que les gens sont malades de
ce qu'il n'arrive pas à dire j'ai un peu
l'impression que c'est un peu le cas de
notre société qui est un peu malade ne
pas pauvre en parler de ces violences
sexuelles dont quoi ya pas un débat où
on va s'opposer ce soir mais au moins on
va en parler donc on va contribuer à sa
merci stéphane adria coiffé tout
votre avis on a l'impression qu'on a ce
scandale qui est en train de sortir de
terre
là dans le monde du sport il ya une
cellule d'écouté qui est mise en place
au ministère du sport
les témoignages affluent les appels
affluent vous mesurer l'ampleur de ce
qui est en train de filmer bien sûr mais
d'ailleurs ce n'est pas que dans le
sport la faire la ferme à 19 une plutôt
de la littérature
adèle haenel on a beaucoup dit que
c'était un nouveau mythe ou du cinéma
mais on a un peu de gens nous rappeler
que cette jeune fille avait 12 ans 14
ans quand ça s'est passé que c'était une
enfant donc progressivement cette omerta
qui ne se limite pas au sport qui se
répondent à l'ensemble de la société est
en train d'exploser enfin la loi du
silence
enfin la parole des enfants des victimes
est en train de se libérer mais le
chemin sont parfois des envies mais oui
la classe et ce à la grande différence
notamment la grande difficulté
spécificités qu'il faut dont il faut
bien avoir conscience par rapport par
exemple aux violences faites aux femmes
et sans opposer évidemment tout type de
violence mais c'est que l'enfant ne
parle pas et quand il parle on a
beaucoup de mal à croire sa parole donc
il ya un enjeu de libération de la
parole et tout ce qui est en train de se
passer là qui qui va ébranler notre
société et ce n'est que le début
ah oui je pense oui parce que ça ça
renvoie des choses c'est par ailleurs
aucun n'est pas écouté il ya le sport de
medellin est bonne au paradis non mais
attendez 80% et quelques 80 % des
violences faites aux enfants
c'est dans le cercle intrafamiliales
c'est dans le cercle de la famille
80% des violences qu'elles soient
physiques psychologiques ou sexuelles
donc effectivement il n'y avait pas de
raison que les violences sexuelles
notamment qu'on constate dans un certain
nombre de la société n'ait pas lieu dans
le sport et je suis désolé je vais te
dire quelque chose de terrible vous
l'avez évoqué les pédocriminels savait
où ils sont ils sont là où il ya des
enfants
c'est simple et c'est comme ça
maintenant
donc oui dans deux disciplines des
choses vont sortir puis dans d'autres
pans de la société des choses on sortir
vous savez aujourd'hui c'est 27 mille
plaintes pour agressions sexuelles sur
enfants chaque année déposé en
ce sens le sait depuis quelques années
on n'a pas attendu et tout le respect
que je reste par éliane carr est
nécessaire que vous faites un moyen de
32 savoir qu à partir de 27 minutes
plainte ça correspond à combien donner
là et vous êtes à fait raison ce ne sont
que les plaintes et donc on peut estimer
que c'est entre 100 et 150 mille âmes en
enfants chaque année qui son élection
qui ne parlent pas qu'ils ne portent pas
atteinte de monaco poser une question
monsieur le ministre que je sois
abassourdi moi je fais du sport toute ma
vie dans quatre disciplines en
compétition et j'ai jamais non seulement
a perçu le moindre symptôme de violences
sexuelles quelle qu'elle soit mais même
je n'ai jamais entendu parler jouer
break sur ses vingt mille et quelques
vous venez de ses limites quelle est la
proportion de violences subies par des
jeunes filles ou des petites filles
éventuellement par les garçons des
petits garçons ce sont des jeux ne parle
que de mineurs oui moi je dis que 80%
des cas des délires en termes de genre
c'est sa version de genre part mis en
garde
c'est plutôt 80% effectivement deux
jeunes filles et 20 % besson met donc
c'est aussi pour sa mère de deux garçons
avec des garçons de neige gelée sous
l'eau on est très loin de considérer que
c'est uniquement le patinage parce que
là pour l'instant le fils qui est en
train de tirer quels sont les sports
tous iront on se rend compte que le foot
la natation le tennis ce qui se passe
aussi c'est que là les gens parlent et
que et qu'il ya eu d'énormes énormément
de candale dans le déni et dans le
silence et encore quelques années
exactement tous les sports sont
concernés on a eu un échantillon assez
large avec l'unc est de 10 close mais
tous les sports sont concernés on le
constate tous les jours nous depuis sept
ans maintenant on à terme peu près 80
milles témoignages et ça concerne
l'ensemble des sports je le crains même
le rugby évidemment même le rugby bien
sûr et pourtant moi même effectivement
sur mon parcours de rugbyman y compris l
équipe de france chez les jeunes justin
une vingtaine d'années je n'ai jamais
changé au quotidien là dans les quelques
jours cette libération de la parole à
l'est les différentes victimes
potentielles victimes
qu'il veut parler parce que vous faites
une association dans votre associé vous
êtes à la fois dans la prévention mais
aussi en aval vous aider les victimes à
porter plainte
exactement à porter plainte et puis à se
soigner aussi dont il a aussi dans le
soin l'accompagnement psychologique
ce qui va changer c'est que la
médiatisation encore une fois c'est la
lumière qui va être porté sur cette
situation on peut être heureux que sarah
abitbol une personnalité une championne
voilà lève le voile là dessus ce que
l'on constate c'est que tous les jours
tous les jours depuis sept ans nous
avons des victimes qui font preuve les
témoignages des victimes qui peut-être
sont certains champions certaines
champions d'autres qui n'ont pas pu
devenir ces champions parce que
justement ils ont été détruits pendant
leur maturité affective
les médias n'ont parlé mais bien sûr que
non mais c'est aussi la volonté d'un
certain nombre de victimes
ils ne souhaitent pas qu'il ne souhaite
pas que ce soit médiatisé qui dans les
questions y compris des champions un qui
ne fait pas et qu'ils peuvent pour
autant s'engager dans ce combat via une
réaction s'arrête denis allumés comme ça
en disant protéger son sport dans le
rugby mais chacun j'imagine protège son
sport en disant ça peut pas arriver chez
nous c'est pas bien commun alors ça
pouvait être qu'un entraîneur ou
éducateur qui viole à 1 min - cadets
vendre une longue enquête ça s'appelle
le revers de la médaille
28 disciplines vous avez trouvez vous
avez enquêté en fait depuis les années
70 ça commence votre documentaire votre
film il ya bien des années
276 victime soixante dix affaires
qu'avez vous découvert qu'avez vous
découvert précisé mois ce qu'un effet de
système
oui ben en fait nous c'était vraiment la
volonté sert quand on a commencé à
travailler je travaille avec deux
confrères là pour dix clauses qui sont
en fait justement devant mathieu
martinière et daphné gastaldi qui avait
déjà travaillé sur les abus sexuels dans
l'église donc je reviens aussi un peu
oublié que vous
vous avez fait tout à l'heure comparable
en fait moi je pense que c'est
comparable dans la mesure où nous
l'encadrent qu'on a fait
elle est partie d'un constat d'un
pressentiment qu'il y avait sans doute
un système est là où moi j'ai
effectivement je me félicite des
reprises qu'il y ait aujourd'hui du des
témoignages ou du témoignage de sarah
abitbol qui est absolument bouleversant
je dis juste que effectivement on avait
travaillé
l'enquêteur il ya quelques mois et la
volonté qu'on avait nous c'était
vraiment de montrer qu'ils avaient un
système
et quand je parle de système c'est à
dire que en fait il y a à la fois des
des responsables ou des prédateurs
disons qu'ils sont dans l'est dans les
clubs et qu'en fait on a constaté que
parfois quand l'alerté donnée soit elle
est étouffée on a documenté ça dans
notre reportage où parfois il ya même
des déprédateurs qui se déplacent d'un
club à l'autre ce qui évidemment se lève
la question du problème de notre
entretien c'est ce que vous nous dites
chacun se protègent en fait je pense
qu'il ya plusieurs facteurs qui sont en
jeu il ya évidemment la difficulté pour
la victime de parler c'est pour ça que
sarah abitbol l'a dit partout elle a été
traumatisée et d'autres paralysaient la
pas pu pas pu parler pendant si
longtemps
il ya un deuxième facteur qui est aussi
que quand dans un petit club
parce qu'en fait ça commence comme ça
aussi les violences sexuelles c'est à
dire que évidemment ça peut concerner
des grands champions des grandes
championnes mais ça commence ces grands
champions ces grandes championnes ils
ont commencé dans des clubs amateurs et
donc nous on a souhaité travailler sur
ces clubs amateurs
et effectivement dans un club amateur
quand ya un entraîneur sur lequel il ya
des soupçons mais qu' il ramène des
médailles le week end et que il fait
vivre a aussi effectué qui fait vivre le
club de du de la région dans les pages
du quotidien régional forcément il ya
aussi un prestige ce qui rend difficile
la possibilité pour le club de dénoncer
l'entraîneur et sa nombreuse l'omerta et
de la famille aussi qui pour le coup se
félicite que leurs enfants soient
accompagnés par ce technicien hors pair
par sept entraîneurs spécialistes et qui
laisse miroiter une carrière en sport
c'est effectuant la notion de
performance qui peut écraser tous et la
question du rapport au corps aussi qui
est particulière dans le sport parce
qu'elle est allée à ses centrales
je devrais vous ramener à l'actualité
avant de débattre des solutions
possibles des mesures possibles
didier gailhaguet gailhaguet on le
patron de la fédération des sports de
glace s'accroche à son poste
les secours découvrent un peu stupéfait
c'est que personne ne peut l'obliger de
partir bah ça c'est la façon dont
effectivement le sport est arrivé en
france avec les fédérations qui sont
assez assez autonome
il ya quand même y aller nommé dans sa
fédération et c'est pour ça d'ailleurs
que le ministère a lancé une procédure
de retrait de la délégation à cette
fédération pour leur permet d'être à ce
genre de procédure c'est écoutez j'ai la
passe en justice bien sûr c'est de vous
dire mais il ya de grandes chances jésus
l'a peut-être pas si l'annoncé ou pas
mais en tout cas qu'il conteste en
justice
effectivement cette cette décision voilà
après sur le sur le fond parce que je
constate c'est qu'on avait quand même un
entraîneur qui avait fait l'objet d'une
enquête en 2001 et dont il avait été
conclu qu'ils ne devaient plus approcher
meyer là que le président en question a
fait en sorte en 2011 qui se retrouve de
nouveau en contact à une mineure dont
partant de là sans payer un moment faut
assumer ses responsabilités qui a une
erre alors dans une faute je crois plus
à parler d'erreur je cours c'est une
faute et que donc ça devrait aboutir une
démission donc vous demander la
démission de
didier gailhaguet je vais y arriver sur
gilles beyer comment c'est possible
qu'il soit encore là cet homme là
comment c'est possible
on est des flyers sur lesquels il est en
train de piloter des entraînements pour
des stages d'été ça semble
incompréhensible alors moi je sais pas
si un système en tout cas il ya de
nombreuses failles dans le système de
protection
il ya des failles d'une part dans ce
qu'on pourrait appeler le contrôle
d'honorabilité des personnes qui sont
mis en contact de nos enfants alors
qu'ils soient éducateur sportif alors là
il ya des contrôles parce qu'il ya des
licences de deux professionnels experts
qui donne lieu à la consultation à
certain nombre de fichiers mais il ya un
sujet qui est complexe mais auquel la
ministre s'est attaquée roxana marie
c'est à nous qui est toute la question
des bénévoles ils sont près des enfants
et on est en train de voir comment faire
en sorte de contrôle et l'honorabilité
aussi des bénévoles
et puis et puis ensuite il ya les
pratiques
c'est à dire qu'il faut s'assurer c'est
bien de mettre en place des fichiers
extra vous l'avez rappelé c'est les gens
qui sont condamnés d'une part qui sont
dans ces fichiers l'a donc encore
faut-il que la parole se soit libéré
qu'il ya eu des plaintes qu'ils soient
condamnés
bon question la libération la parole
pour évoquer tout à l'heure et ensuite
il faut que les gens qui sont censés
consulter les fichiers fasse
effectivement et c'est tout l'objet du
travail qu'on a lancés y est avec nicole
belloubet et roxanne mailloux sur lequel
on reviendra peut-être ce que yarmand
faut qu'on s'assure que les choses
soient effectives c'est bien de en faire
des fichiers du fichier des infractions
sexuelles où on va en parler il ya la
question du casier du judiciaire on va
voir un extrait de de votre travail de
votre documentaire faut-il que le casier
judiciaire des entraîneurs bénévoles
soit véritablement contrôler vous avez
montré qu'on pouvait embaucher un
pédophile dans un club dans une
fédération de tir à l'arc en toute
impunité regarder à la fédération de tir
à l'arc
nous arrivons chargé des diplômes un
signalement
comment les instances sportives ont
elles pu laisser entrer un pédophile
condamné dans les clubs bretons nous
avons posé la question à l'un des grands
patrons de la fédération benoît bino et
directeur technique national nommé par
le ministère des sports
est ce que pour obtenir un diplôme
d'entraîneur il doit montrer un extrait
de casier judiciaire
papa pour les diplômes fédéraux comme à
chaque fois dans cette enquête
il reconnaît que le casier judiciaire
des entraîneurs bénévoles n'est jamais
contrôler ça c'est la faute aux deux
diplômes d'entraîneur 1
ça c'était en 2011 en 2014 il est à
nouveau il a un deuxième diplôme au
niveau supérieur
tout à fait toujours pas de contrôle de
gaz et toujours pas de contrôle de casey
est ce que c'est un problème selon robin
aujourd'hui on peut que constater que en
tout cas il ya des failles
voilà elle rien taquet on ne peut
constater que des failles de ce que je
vous ai redit d'ivresse ça veut dire
quoi c'est sûr ça va être fait
systématiquement sinon c'est ce à quoi
on est en train de travailler parce
qu'il ya des rôles en l'occurrence si
vous avez des fédérations où il ya les
bénévoles sont sous licence et c'est le
cas d'ailleurs du cac ont voilà pourquoi
comme quoi et d'autres où ce n'est pas
le cas donc là aussi cette problématique
la prendre en considération mais l'idée
enfin il ya une expérimentation
effectivement qu'on mène en fait le rock
ça n'amène dans la région centre val de
loire avec la fédération française de
foot et l'idée s'est très rapidement de
voilà de valider cette expérimentation
et pouvoir l'étendre et si je peux me
permettre
le fichier le fameux fige est-ce donc
c'est le fichier des agresseurs sexuels
et justement selon nous plus plus solide
à cet égard que le casier judiciaire
parce que le sait les infractions
sexuelles qui sont qui sont portés à ce
fichier là elle reste pour 20 ans 30 ans
minimum en fonction de la nature des
infractions
c'est moins la tournerie qu'est ce que
vous vous attendez des pouvoirs publics
on a cette parole libérée maintenant que
l'omerta se brise
alors on en tombe que je publie parce
que je me disais que ça allait pas de
charline une seule fois donc on a
l'impression que le fait que c'est
libéré ça y est
effectivement il y aurait également
plusieurs étapes par rapport à cela mais
de notre côté en contact avec les
victimes et avec aussi le mouvement
sportif qui aussi pour la plupart en
difficulté quand même hein donc d'abord
nous on s'attache effectivement à ne pas
faire la chasse aux sorcières on a un
discours qui à la fois s'adresse aux
jeunes pour se protéger mais aussi aux
éducateurs aux intendants aux dirigeants
pour mieux protéger les jeunes et mieux
se protéger aussi d'accord montrozier
aussi dans leurs institutions leurs
structures
mais ce qu'il faut c'est peut-être
renforcer la prévention des jeunes et de
ces adultes qui gravitent autour
mais par exemple il faut il faut la
deuxième entraîneur sportif
non mais il faut apprendre aux jeunes
d'abord à identifier leurs parties
intimes d'identifier leurs cours savoir
dire non en parler en parler un adulte
de confiance née hanffou derrière donc
c'est à dire qu'il faut les former ces
jeunes là c'est ce que l'on fait dans
les écoles c'est ce jeune tom qui
veulent voir l'issue d'une intervention
dans une école pour me dire que
finalement ils étaient victimes de
violences pas sexuel lui mais des
violences de la part de sa maman à la
maison qui le borde et c'est cette jeune
athlète qui vient nous voir encore pour
me dire qu'elle subissait des violences
sexuelles qu'elle avait parlé à son
entraîneur et qui ne s'était rien passé
mais c'est aussi ses débuts cet
éducateur cet entraîneur de handball qui
a viré un certain nombre de jeunes de
son équipe
parce qu'il avait fait du bizutage
aggravé et qu' il fallait absolument
condamnées ça donc c'est tout et
d'action finalement qu'il faut mener en
fait c'est oui c'est intéressant je
réagis par rapport à ça nous c'est aussi
ce qu'on a constaté c'est à dire que en
termes de prévention par exemple on a
travaillé sur un cas qui est très
révélateur où on interrogé le président
d'un club de tennis de table qui avait
en son sein quelques uns qui avait été
condamné auparavant pour pour des
violences sexuelles et en fait il ne
connaissait pas les outils à sa
disposition pour traiter ce cas c'est à
dire qu'il était au courant qu'il y
avait eu quelque chose mais il ne savait
pas déjà qu'il y avait un article de loi
dans le code du sport qui est l'article
212-13 longtemps fait les présidents de
clubs ne savent pas que
la loi les ans leur interdit évidemment
de d'embaucher quelqu'un dans un club au
contact de mineurs potentiellement qui a
été condamné et en fait on vous vouliez
parler des solutions moi je me félicite
aussi de la tribune qui a eu avant hier
ou avant-hier dans le parisien qui a été
signé là vous l'avez dit notamment
partie de 54 sportif qui reprend en fait
des solutions qu'on avait proposé aussi
à l'époque où l'enquêté était sorti ou
dispose avait sorti l'anc est la
première des propositions c'est de créer
un organe indépendant et en fait je
reviens juste là dessus je voudrais
développer un tout petit peu en fait que
ce dont on a beaucoup parlé on en attend
s'est longuement entretenu avec la
ministre à ce sujet aussi la grosse
difficulté difficultés dans le sport
c'est ce qu'on appelle le conflit de
loyauté c'est à dire que c'est très
difficile pour un athlète de parler en
tout cas d'être en antagonisme entre
guillemets en tout cas de s'opposer
disons un entraîneur a fortiori à un
club dont on porte les couleurs toutes
les compétitions tous les week-ends
tout ce qu'on fait du sport le savent et
donc c'est du coup c'est très compliqué
et on la sphère gailhaguet le montre le
sport c'est un petit milieu en fait et
c'est exactement ce que les gens
découvrent d'ailleurs qu'elle est
tellement petit que tout le monde s'il
ne savait pas moins avaient des doutes 1
exactement et sacchi saisissant et c'est
pour ça que je pense que c'est une bonne
proposition et que la ministre je crois
d'ailleurs s'est prononcée plutôt
favorablement à ce genre de proposition
et à mon avis il est intéressant
aujourd'hui d'étudier la possibilité de
faire un organe de contrôle qui soit
indépendant pour que justement pour
faciliter la libération de la parole et
que les histoires soient vraiment
enquêter jusqu'au bout et qu'on ne soit
pas face ajustement des réseaux très
étroit
comment vous regardez vous ce qu'est en
train de semer je vous entends dire tout
le monde de des doutes
quand on écoute la ministre j'ai envie
de vous poser une autre question si le
ministre est peut-être là monsieur
latournerie aussi puisque bon était un
sportif de haut niveau vous avez fait
tout le cursus 1 depuis les minimes
jusqu'à l'équipe première et même si
j'ai bien compris l'équipe de france
pour les jeunes de moins de 20 ans
est-ce que c'est comme est-ce que marché
malgré tout sur l'allée des millions qui
sont licenciés est-ce que c'est à ça
reste marginal ou est ce que c'est
vraiment puisqu'il y en a beaucoup mais
j'ai déjà mes quatre enfants ont été
dans les clubs sportifs aussi certains
encore jamais entendu parler de rien du
tout alors est ce que c'est vraiment
est-ce que c'est quelques cas qu'il faut
il faut que vous ouvriez monsieur le
ministre mais est-ce que c'est quelqu'un
parce que c'est vraiment quelque chose
qui gangrène le sport de façon globale
c'est très bien d'ailleurs non mais
c'est très bien de poser cette question
là et et aussi pour rassurer les
familles quoi qu'il en soit on est des
amoureux du sport je laisse mon fils
dans tel ou tel club
tu peux pas m'en voyez là-bas
voilà exactement c'est un argument tout
trouvé pour mais non évidemment c'est
très important le sport de belles
valeurs il faut encore une fois les
mettre en avant
la pédocriminalité dans le sport comme
ailleurs c'est d'abord le fait de
personnes malveillantes
d'accord les personnes qui utilisent le
sport et des failles dans le sport pour
agir c'est la séparation de parents
c'est la difficulté de certains parents
un contexte particulier ils vont en tant
que prédateur s'infiltrer dans cette
danse est voilà donc non heureusement la
situation
la saison est grave quoi qu'il en soit
mais le nombre de victimes d'une
certaine façon et est moins importante
que le monde de nos sacs la comparaison
avec l'église est délicate parce que
l'éducation nationale madame
non je ne sais pas les ministres avaient
relevé des vous l'avez dit des endroits
d'adultes pour l'église pour avoir suis
un petit peu d des intervenants dans mon
france victime et qui a une structure
qui accueille quelques unes ce numéro d'
alerte pour les témoignages et des
victimes dans l'église il me rendais
compte que il y avait finalement eu
mille appels fin la première année c'est
à dire trois par jour trois par jour ah
je trouve que c'est quand même assez
c'est quand même important et d'un fort
tous les jours nous avons plusieurs
plusieurs témoignages tous les jusqu'à
et tout jusqu'à cinq ou six signalement
au procureur au procureur par mois voilà
et une fois encore c'est 80% des
violences c'est dans le cadre familial
il faut pas que les familles soient
soient effectivement inquiète-t-elle
faut qu'elle soit jugée lente vigilant
mais et responsabilise responsabiliser
aussi c'est à dire que effectivement
parler à son enfant dès qu'il a 5 ans 4
5 ans moi je le fais avec mon fils de 4
ans j'ai peut-être un billet parce que
je travaille sur cette question non mais
de du rapport au corps
la notion de consentement dans d'autres
mots du fait qu'il ya pas de poésie ça
personnellement part il ya pas de petits
secrets
y a pas de petits secrets on attend
entre un adulte et wav et comme jamais
ya de petits secrets faut que tu me
parles de main voilà ça commence par là
l'école a un rôle à jouer
les parents ou un rôle à jouer l'école a
un rôle à jouer à cet égard nous on
pense qu'il faut démultiplier les lieux
où il ya cette sensibilisation parce que
c'est aussi des moments de libération
parle j'ai à chaque fois qu'ils font une
intervention et toutes les assos de dix
trains dans un club dans une école etc
ça à la fin il ya toujours deux gamins
qui viennent pour dire qu'ils ont subi
des violences 1 donc il faut aussi
mobiliser le temps périscolaire on veut
bosser avec les maires pour tout le
temps périscolaire dans les communes
puissent être mobilisés pour ça donc
tout ce travail de prévention hyper
importante
il ya le fichier il faut renforcer
l'effectivité mais il ya peut-être des
propositions qui émanent de députés et
vous aurez le mot de la fin juste après
c'est au tour des des solutions écouter
les propositions d'une ancienne
patineuse
venu députés à l'assemblée nationale il
s'agit d'agnès firmin le bodo hélène
bonduelle la rencontre et comment dans
toutes les associations parce que il ya
le sport la culture la toux enfin la
société en général comment dans tous les
lieux d'ailleurs presque public
on met d'abord peut-être le numéro 39 19
qui est encore assez peu connu comment
on explique aux enfants que dès la
première dès la première photo on reçoit
dès le premières caresses pas tout à
fait normal c'est pas normal qu'un homme
fasse une petite caresse comme ça on
puisse avoir quelqu'un de référent à qui
parler et puis comment aussi on sort de
cette présomption d'innocence ou en
laisse en place des éducateurs dont on
peut penser que plutôt que d'essayer de
protéger les éventuelles victimes
je pense qu'il faut aussi dans ce cas là
est capable de renverser la machine
pourquoi pas aussi les jeunes qui se les
jeunes éducateurs sportifs pas leur
faire passer un essai un espèce de tests
de moralité mais pourquoi pas aussi
moi je veux dire qu'il faut mettre tout
l'arsenal possibles et toutes les
chances de notre côté pour que ça
n'arrive plus ça brise des vies et ça
n'est pas possible ça n'est plus
possible
voilà ya des idées et compris ça les
bancs de l'assemblée à des tests de
moralité joyet hausser les sourcils et
houba plutôt fort mais je pense que
c'est du travail qu'ils font est
d'ailleurs j'ai assisté j'étais au creps
avec ce pied d'argile avec roxane
américiane et où d'ailleurs prévisible
de france formée sensibiliser les
professionnels à faire prendre
conscience d'une part qu'on est très
alerte sur le sujet et que l'espèce
d'ambiance un peu de laisser-aller
laisser faire c'est pas si grave que ça
et s'est terminée en fait voilà quel que
soit le milieu c'est terminé maintenant
on ne laissera plus rien passer et puis
les sensibiliser les former à à des
façons de se comporter qui sont un peu
plus respectueuse des enfants voilà
merci merci on va terminer avec
peut-être votre passé d'éditeur je
voulais avoir votre sentiment là-dessus
puisque on a parlé de gabriel matzneff
et de et de cette affaire autour de
l'île de vanessa spring aura le
consentement
vous vous avez refusé d'éditer son
journal tout de suite suivez pourquoi il
restait comme auteur il était bien avant
moi
trente avant moi
à la table ronde et je continue à
publier des essais philosophiques et
autres pourquoi pas ce que je vais
regarder quand même et j'avais vu je
m'étais d'ailleurs étonné que il n'est
jamais fait l'objet de procédures
judiciaires était question d'un enfant
de neuf ans c'est un journal c'est pas
un journal un calmant précisément j'ai
pris le tableau donne au printemps 90 je
lui ai dit je la table ronde
tant que j'y serai ne te publiera pas
que vous lui dites ça et vous en parlait
dans le monde de l'e 10 n'était pas
content il a dû me jugé prudent
et oui et il est à lille soumettre cela
hier c'était les rieurs mais mais mais
simplement il ya eu un débat les
décisions non m'at il dit c'est ouais le
est un espèce d'atmosphère de bigoterie
moraliste qui s'instaure dans ce pays
sahélien n'a pas trop souffert pendant
des années il attendit sont souvent
celles de rendez vous qui l'avez avec
des gens par seconde édition est une
compagnie une complaisance je le dis
puisque je n'ai jamais créé jusqu'au
plus haut sommet de l'état le président
de la république de l'époque le recevait
l'apprécié pas forcément pour pour ça du
tout ce que je veux dire elle appréciait
surtout je crois c et c'est son temps
puis c'était le côté d'or nice ont été
un moment où les déconstructeurs 68 eur
avait quand même relativiser les noms
oui ben j'en ai vraiment c'était oui je
me sentais isolée parce que je voyais
bien que denise bombardier a dénoncé sa
prof avec chez pivot en présence de
maternelle dès lundi dans mon pays où
seriez en taule
tout le monde a rigolé on a dit c'est de
mal baisées quoi essai de réac
on a dit ça m'a écouté merci d'avoir
fait même si on n'a pas cessé de faire
d'autre sur le plan moral
d'ailleurs vous assumez un réac qui
s'assume merci à tous d'être venus
débattre on va parler maintenant d'un
grand homme un monument ce monsieur l'a
écouté c'était en 1958 au dessus des
querelles politiques
il existe un arbitre national par les
citoyens y ont un mandat public qui soit
chargée d'assurer le fonctionnement
régulier des institutions il existe un
gouvernement qui soit fait pour
gouverner à qui honda ne s
le pape et la possibilité qu'il existe
un parlement destiné à représenter la
volonté politique de la nation a voté
les lois à contrôler l'exécutif mais
sans sortir de charles ça vous fait quoi
de le voir comme ça à chaque fois ou
presque quand on fouille on sent l'amour
rien parce que il était c'est un héros
un héros n'est pas un seul n'est pas un
sage il a connu beaucoup d'échecs il a
été sujet des des mélancolies des doutes
des moments presque des dépressifs mais
bon effectivement quand il a quitté le
pouvoir en mai passé du sacré au profane
je peux dire il
il avait installé son rôle à une telle
la tactilité altitude que tous les
autres en ont pâti d' pour ça que
c'était si difficile pour son successeur
immédiat pompidou qui fut un très bon
prêt si vous deviez dire à des jeunes
qui n'ont pas connu qui ne font que lé
étudié en classe d'histoire s'il y avait
une leçon à tirer
il ya un moment où les vertus ordinaire
qu'il faut respecter qui ont été
inculquées par les parents mais quand
quelque chose de plus important qu'on
peut se sentir nous pousse à lire
régularité pour devenir un aventurier il
faut il céder et c'est ce qu'a fait de
gaulle le 17 juin 1940 alors vous dites
d'ailleurs dans votre lait que l'urgence
pour les générations à venir et de
redécouvrir le sens de l'honneur de la
grandeur de l'insoumission aussi vous
écrivez franchement une forme de prêt si
aussi de gouvernance à travers ce
dictionnaire à l'intention d'un certain
emmanuel macron gants oui c'est vrai que
j'ai
assez souvent pensé au président de la
république quand j'ai écrit ce livre au
monde à lui à quelques prédécesseurs que
j'ai pu connaître personnellement parce
que bon on va on va commémorer de gaulle
beaucoup cette année la date de son
décès le 10 juin
mais j'ai peur qu'on le noie sous les
louages en disant ouais mais c'était une
autre époque et c'est plus possible
maintenant non l'art de bien gouverner
assumant pas changé depuis les césars
depuis le colbert louvois depuis le
cardinal de richelieu de piles le
premier consul depuis clemenceau en 17
on n'a pas changé c'est possible non pas
de singer de gaulle mais deux
d'exercer le pouvoir à l'altitude
requise par la nature des institutions
vais vous montrer deux images une plus
traire et sensible c'est le président de
la république aux côtés d'un dessinateur
jul c'est en marge du festival
d'angoulême vous la voyez cette image
cette photo elle a beaucoup circulé dans
les médias sur les réseaux sociaux avec
ce tee shirt lbd 2020 très clairement
pour dénoncer les violences policières
puis on a d'autres on pourra en prendre
beaucoup d'autres mais après une c'était
pendant la coupe du monde de football
regardez-le c'est emmanuel macron qui
savoure le but marqué c'est tout ce
qu'il ne faut pas faire oui c'est tout
ce qu'il faut pas fermer de ne
l'accablons pas hollande et sarkozy qui
sont des copains par ailleurs eux aussi
ont contribué à désacraliser la fonction
soit il peut être c'est d'abord
peut-être que par les temps qui courent
c'est pas facile il faut il faut savoir
se tenir quand on est président de la
république parce qu'on n'est pas le chef
d'un exécutive même comme monsieur
johnson ou la chancelière merkel 1 on
est assis sur le trône élyséen sûr qu'un
siècle d'inconscient monarchique qu'un
siècle vous en parlait d'ailleurs en l
occurrence ut il ya ces retenues soute
robonaut 2 de gaulle à la fois de cet
homme qui était soit en habit militaire
ou en costume cravate mais qui était un
homme droit qui savait se tenir ça on
sent que c'est très important pour vous
il savait se tenir lors ya cette
question de tenue car après ça les
équipes qui allaient pair avec le fait
que sa parole était rare solennel
ces décisions c'est à s'entourer de
secret il l'avait
il l'avait défini d'ailleurs parlé dans
le fil de l'épée dès la fin des années
20 quand tfc son premier essai et
définissent qui je suis vous dites que
savoir se tenir la parole rare quand on
se souvient des débuts des manuels macro
élus souvenez-vous de ses conseillers le
golo mitterrandien la verticalité
alors voilà le président les bons sens
ma croix a envie d'être gaullien enfin
le désir assez profondément ça je lui je
lui fais ce crédit et les débuts du
quinquennat ont correspondu à ce désir
il a était solennel est un peu un peu
distant il faut une distance il
il a voulu faire de la proximité parce
que des colons communicants lui ont dit
que c'est comme ça que ça se passe
1 mais de gaulle avec une proximité avec
personne y compris ses plus proches
collaborateurs il avait une intimité
avec le pape il allait prendre des
bonnes foules et faire des voyages en
province à l'étranger intimité n'est pas
proximité oui il faut on est dans un
monde aux avec la fois un contenu et les
ré et les réseaux sociaux
il faut que plus jamais plus que jamais
le président protège sa mission et
surdité
par exemple il comme institution aurait
pu en parler beaucoup d'elle tous les
héros historique condé vient au zig zag
traversée d'abord du dream écrivez-vous
à propos de gaulle et et vous dites au
contraire qu' il n'y a qu'un h majuscule
pour de gaulle qui était un homme
finalement sans histoire ou en tout cas
où avec une escale au privé n'a aucun
intérêt il n'est pas anecdotique
il n'est pas à pas de maîtresse et il
n'est pas il n'y a pas d'exode vacances
il vivait comme un homme de son milieu
avec les goûts banal il regarde 1 télé
le soir il faisait des réussites et puis
puis voilà donc ce dandy soi et g et
l'homme public par contre et avait
conscience de son inscription dans
l'histoire dans la mémoire longue de la
france ouais ce que j'aurais envie de
dire au président macron de lui rappeler
pitot c'est ce que de gaulle a dit un
jour un de ses collaborateurs je crois
que ces gars sont pas le ski le dis
attention
d'abord la france après seulement l'état
et puis après le droit on écrirait
certains ont l'impression qu'ils ont
tout rond qu'ils ont inversé
dictionnaire amoureux du général fait
beaucoup des dictionnaires vous à
commencer par la france
il ya eu le catholicisme aujourd'hui
c'est de gaulle cette audition plomb et
on picore comme ça ces avantages des
dictionnaires un petit chapitre quand on
le souhaite c'est passionnant vous
restez avec nous on va parler d'un tout
autre sujet serait-il plus difficile
d'être asiatique en 70 corona burriss la
crise sanitaire que traversent les
habitants de rujano chine a rouvert
évidemment la boîte de pandore du
racisme anti chinois maïté frémont a
rencontré eu à rencontrer une française
d'origine chinoise qui vit dans la
capitale
elle explique qu'elle est interpellé de
façon assez inhabituelle
écoutez son témoignage déjà que voulu
innover avec vos mères devenu titulaire
je suis pas grossir est maintenant votre
virus cette chinoise
et puis il a continué son chemin ces
propos christine les a pris en pleine
figure
la scène se déroule mercredi dernier
dans un quartier bourgeois de paris
et pour cette française d'origine
chinoise c'est le choc
la dernière fois que j'étais allé en
chine c'était un séjour linguistique
c'était dans les années 2000 j'étais
encore étudiante en droit ça fait il ya
vingt ans j'ai plus de familles en chine
j'ai l'impression que tout d'un coup
j'ai c'était tout était de ma faute et
j'ai pas compris en fait jamais
christine n'aurais pensé que ses
origines serait un jour assimilé à un
virus elle en rit et même avec son
compagnon
bah si ça arrive dans l'école des
enfants ben oui ce serait il ce qu'on
l'ait coupable tout trouvé
bah tiens ça va être chouette dommage
qu'à pas les grèves sur un petit peu
plus de place dans le métro mais
vraiment de l'humour de l'humour mais
face à ce déferlement de haine christine
décide comme de nombreuses autres
victimes de poster son témoignage sur
les réseaux sociaux
leclerc des virus et le racisme alors si
tu rajoutes l'imbécillité l'ignorance
depuis plusieurs jours la psychose et la
stigmatisation se propage là beaucoup de
de fakka qui arrivent de chine a rien
collègues je vais pas les distribuer
toute façon j'ai un marchand de légumes
qui est chinois j'ai toujours acheté mes
frais d'une chez lui mais je vais pas
acheter le reste ça ne fait pas et le le
gars qui dans le métro ce lait parce
qu'il ya un chinois qui s'assied à côté
de lui
c'est le la personne qui relève son
écharpe parce que il entend tout c est
que c'est un fait un asiatique quelqu'il
soit parce qu'après on confond tous les
chinois les japonais les viennent à
merida et donc tout ça ça fait que ça
mais quand même une ambiance un petit
peu désagréable le coronavirus est-il un
prétexte à un racisme anti asiatique
c'est en tout cas ce que dénonce
l'acteur frédéric chau qui n'a pas du
tout aimé l'un des dernier sketch de
nicolas canteloup faut attraper châtain
chinoise impérativement oui bah écoutez
ou fait ce que vous pouvez vous l'attiré
comme vous voulez vous mais je ne sais
pas moi des nems en ligne sur le
trottoir
c'est au bout une grande tempête à
chinois doit pas non mais écoutez ne
doit pas nous échapper
christine elle interroge ce soir les
élus la plupart des élus sont blancs
donc ils ont ils ont ils ont jamais été
aussi agressé enfin et quand ça concerne
ça n'arrive pas soit rends toi compte du
mal que ça peut faire pour ce type de
comportement raciste qui a réagi et nous
ont rejoints sur ce plateau stéphanie
d'eau bonsoir merci d'être là vous êtes
député la république en marche de seine
et marne à vos côtés julien ma'i de
bonsoir vous est la fondatrice de khoy
magazine le premier magazine en france
dédié à la communauté asiatique et enfin
j'accueille lindau bonsoir bonsoir est
journaliste à france info vous ont valu
à partir de ce reportage
ça vous surprend ce témoignage de cette
de cette française d'origine chinoise ou
pas je pense que fo légère électives et
relativiser tout ça parce que je pense
que la situation est stable en france il
n'y a pas d'épidémie
il n'ya pas de chaîne de transmission en
france il existe cas confirmés depuis la
semaine dernière dont il faut pas fait
tout atar la peur la panique
bien sûr mais ça c'est cette jeune femme
est interpellé violemment
oui dans la rue est ce que pour vous
c'est forcément liés à cette épidémie la
qui forcément vient de chine ça c'est
indéniable qui suscite des craintes ou
il ya quelque chose de fou qui se
réveille dans une forme de rage je pense
qu'il était un jeune qui profite sur la
situation c'est le moment le défouler ou
si c'est quand même du racisme des idées
et nos phobies ou 6 1
c'est au moment de se défouler pour ses
plaisirs tout simplement les nanas où
vous avez lancé vous sur votre compte
twitter un appel à témoins oui il avait
reçu beaucoup de témoignages ou ont pas
mal
une dizaine mais en fait j'ai lancé cet
appel à témoin pour être sûr que ce
n'était pas juste un petit à petit
phénomène et je me suis aperçu qu'en
fait il y avait beaucoup de personnes
dans mon entourage proche et des
inconnus qui ont vécu des situations où
ils ont été insultés ou non les à éviter
donc c'est pas du tout un phénomène
isolé un ce témoignage qu'on a
entendu il ya quelques oui en fait quand
j'entends son témoignage je suis
surprise oui et non en fait je savais
qu'il y avait déjà un racisme anti
asiatique l'attend en france et je n'ai
en fait je ne sais je ne pensais pas que
les gens profiterait du coronavirus pour
déverser leur haine et c'est ce qui est
en train de se passer ils se servent du
court aux navires us comme d'un prétexte
pour pour déverser tous tous les clichés
racistes qu'ils ont déjà à la base sur
les asiatiques
juliet miles ce racisme donc de quoi
procède ciel est ce que vous avez
l'impression que les racistes anti
asiatique ont l'impression de l'être
donc non non non non non très souvent
c'est une blague
il faut pas le prendre comme ça c'était
juste pour te taquiner et c'est souvent
les gens on voit beaucoup sur les
réseaux sociaux en les gens veulent
avoir la petite blague le mot qui fait
rire il se sentir un peu intéressants il
va l'être tweets et ils veulent qu'on
aime lors leur poste et c'est donc on
fait plutôt pour être intéressant pour
faire lire sa cour et on ne se rend pas
forcément compte que en face il ya des
personnes des humains qui sont blessés
et qu'ils en ont marre d'entendre ces
réflexions parce que peut-être que c'est
marrant comme ça de faire une blague
sauf que ces personnes là en général
reçoivent ce type de blagues trois
quatre cinq fois par jour même plus en
ce moment c'est l'hécatombe est vrai
qu'au bout d'un moment c'est c'était
difficile des blagues
il ya aussi des insultes et des
agressions sur les réseaux sociaux ça
déborde ça déborde il ya des agressions
aussi dans les écoles parce que nous
effectivement on va pas se bousculer
dans le métro c'est arrivé mais de
manière assez isolé mais par contre à
l'école ya des gens qui se bousculent
qui ce qui se crachent dessus etc ou là
on commence vraiment à dépasser les
limites
comment vous regardez ce jour je crois
pas qu'ils aient de profondément de
raciste chinois en tout cas qui vous
prennent qui bonne source dans les
profondeurs de l'inconscient collectif
on n'a jamais eu de garde de conflit
direct avec la chine
bon un peu avec l'indochine mais bon une
communauté asiatique à base de dinde aux
chinois et de chinois d'un 13e en
naissant de paris
relation jamais été conflictuelles avec
les français de souche comme un gant
alors effectivement on parle de la chine
différemment il ya une espèce de peur de
la chine depuis quelques années un com
comme si on était en train de se rendre
compte que des sportifs tout à
l'heure dans la géopolitique on se
rapprocher de la finale et la finale
elle opposera les états unis à la chine
et nous on est un peu largué et on
parlait des pros des performances
chinoise en économie qui vont dépasser
un jour celle des états unis on parle de
la route de la soie en parle de choses
qui font que regard sur le chinois
probablement
c'est pas une sinophobie c'est peut-être
une méfiance une inquiétude france est
un fonds de 1 for rural de ces nantis de
paysannerie on se méfie toujours de
celui qui arrive fils du village voisin
je sens que ça pour la montée en
puissance de la guerre commerciale entre
les états unis et la chine on parle de
la chine comme d'une puissance qui est
éventuellement peut faire peur parce que
parce que voilà les chinois sont
nombreux et puis je pense que ça a
rejoint un petit peu c'est cet
imaginaire ça fait ça fait ça fait appel
aux peurs profondes qui je pense sont
hérités de l'époque coloniale en fait
d'ailleurs le président suivait même la
guerre d'indochine
oui oui peut-être et le rire reste
quelque chose mais c'est beaucoup moins
prévenant que les séquelles de la guerre
d'algérie pendant nos rapports avec nos
compatriotes mieux mais le président
chinois accuse même donald trump en ce
moment dans ce contexte d'épidémie
au fond d'eux d'une certaine forme de
dénigrement oui et puis on appelle cela
le coronavirus le virus chinois moi je
me souviens pas qu'on ait déjà appelé
d'autres virus le virus américain
le virus européen le virus africains
pour ebola je n'ai pas entendu par
exemple donc c'est vrai qu'il ya une
stigmatisation une exotique à sion de ce
virus et je peux comprendre qu'on se
sente d'une certaine manière agressé en
tout cas aujourd'hui les chinois en
france se sentent mal à l'aise par
l'ancien stéphanois d'eau on l'a même vu
les nations unies se sont émus de la
manière dont donald trump notamment un
cd de au fond instrumentaliser cette
épidémie est ce ce rapport de forces
aussi un kit avec la fille vous vous
êtes inquiète
je pense que c'est de notre ombre on le
connaît le sait bien il faut se fait
parler de lui
donc je rentre pas dans ce que vous
dites vous considérez que aller chez le
mondial depuis cette épidémie due à une
forme de stigmatisation un petit peu
systématiques
je pense que je pense qu'il ya une
certaine aussi au delà de l'aspect du
racisme d'une autre fille je pense qu'il
ya aussi à de la jalousie
jalousé par rapport la réussite chinoise
guen craintes il ya une crainte de cette
licence
il va débuter bientôt la première
puissance mondiale dont il ya aussi pas
mal de manipulation car il n'y a pas mal
vous savez ce que c'est les états unis
et la chine
moi même si d'origine vietnamienne je
sais ce que c'est à la guerre
d'indochine c'est toujours entre au
milieu avec les grandes puissances qui
essayent de manipuler pour que l'on
était d'ailleurs ces deux bonnets pulls
le viet lindau et un journaliste de
slate qui a écrit cette semaine qui est
il aura fallu le corona ferrus pour que
je cite saisir que la maladie du racisme
anti asiatique se niche dans notre chère
est la raison où ça va un peu loin jure
je pense que le racisme anti asiatique
on a déjà commencé à en parler en 2006
avec la mort du couturier chinois chang
shaolin dennis tabassé à mort 2016 ray
en 2016
il a été tabassé à mort parce que l'on
pensait qu'il a son agresseur pensait
qu'ils avaient de l'argent liquide sur
lui et je pense que c'est que la vraie
prise de conscience de l'existence d'un
racisme anti asiatique a commencé à ce
moment là
je pense que c'est à ce moment là aussi
que plein de personnes en fait se sont
engagés en fait dans le militantisme est
effectivement le court aux navires us
c'est quelque chose qui kira kira vivent
à un racisme anti asiatique qui je pense
est déjà latent alors incident - de ces
gaziers atik je vais vous montrer un
extrait assez édifiants dont on parle
beaucoup moins que le racisme anti-noir
que le racisme antimaghrébin comment
vous l'expliquez on dit souvent que la
communauté asiatique est très intégrée
discrète
est ce que c'est pour ça que on est pas
capable de donner la place publique
médiatique qu'il convient pour dénoncer
ce type de dénigrement de racisme moi
j'ai l'habitude de le faire un pas de
côté dans l'est on dit parce qu'en 2010
a déjà eu des manifestations de
personnes d'origine asiatique à
belleville il y en a eu à nouveau en
2011 quand le couturier zhang gaoli
n'est mort à aubervilliers a été
agressée aubervilliers il ya eu des
manifestations en 2016 il y en a eu
encore après pour d'autres cas donc il
ya des mobilisations
il faut parfois aussi tendre l'oreille
regardez qui manifestent tendre les
micros aussi il ya aussi la
responsabilité des médias d'aller vers
ces communautés pour savoir aussi ce
qu'elles revendiquent elles sont quels
sont les problèmes qui les préoccupent
donc peut-être que pour la première
génération d'immigrés les
primo-arrivants ceux qui sont arrivés
tôt dans les années 70 80
peut-être qu'ils ont une certaine
reconnaissance envers la france de les
avoir accueillis de les avoir sauvés
d'une certaine manière se sentent
redevables qui se sont dit on va pas
faire de vagues
mais comme pour beaucoup d'immigrés
beaucoup d'immigrés de première
génération se disent bon si tu reçois
une insulte toujours fait profil bas
profil barre si on avait reçu en caisse
et voilà et souvent les enfants eux se
disent non mais moi je suis français
j'ai grandi en france
effectivement mon physique est différent
de la section depuis des générations
mais j'avoue montré un extrait justement
d'un exemple d'un asiatique qui fait
profil bas qui accepte tous est assez
édifiant c'est pour comprendre au fond
que ce dénigrement là il dépasse
largement la crainte d'un virus
venus de chine c'est un reportage
réalisé en 2002 ça se passe à levallois
perret dans la permanence de campagne de
patrick balkany c'est une séquence avec
isabelle balkany est l'un de ses
employées municipales d'origine
cambodgienne regarder véronique isabelle
continue de travailler comme si de rien
n'était regardez bien ces mains qui
s'agitent ce son bras c'est un employé
de la mairie qui évite notre caméra tous
les soirs après ces heures de bureau il
vient masse et sa patronne c'est lui il
est cambodgien son surnom grain de riz
vous pouvez appeler mon mari mais alors
maintien craindre il va donner mais le
bon téléphone a pas de vie est d'accord
on va vous emmener le téléphone
certains grains de riz a maintenu sa
patrie sans même temps des choix jerry
flannery c'est un petit peu de people
qu'on l'installé ac est venu à levallois
il ya vingt ans et chirac qu'il allait
demander de prendre des boat people dans
les villes et il est venu avec toute sa
famille
c'est un boat people et il a un nom pas
possible il s'appelle alors ont d'abord
on l'a baptisé maurice et plus on trouve
pas ça drôle et un jour j'ai baptisé
grainerie et toute la mairie les taux
courrier à la mairie toute la mairie la
perdrix ses cadres y fait on l'a d'abord
vexin c'est vrai que pour les vu de
l'extérieur ça fait bizarre
une réaction gmail moi je suis écoeuré
là je tombe des nues j'essaie de me
rassurer en me disant que c'était en
2002 que les choses ont dû évoluer
voilà c'était en 2002 j'espère que les
choses ont évolué et j'espère que ce
monsieur a pris un peu plus d'assurance
et se rend compte que de la
condescendance avec avec laquelle on l'a
traité et que maintenant il ne se sent
plus redevable de faire tout ce qu'on
lui demande
on a l'impression que absolument pas
tabou les objectifs à presque une
volonté d'assumer koala une certaine
certaines formes valade
c'est pas le comportement d'une
bourgeoise avec son employée de maison
je ne sais pas si en europe et en fait
qui qualifie le racisme anti asiatique
c'est que les il ya des préjugés positif
donc ça on l'a on n'a pas toujours vu
comme comme une sorte de racisme mais
c'est une forme de racisme à un préjugé
même positif reste un prix juste et
c'est à dire ils sont sympas ils sont
discrets ils font pas de vagues et le
message que sont le chômage
le message que je vois c'est non pas dès
la séquence crème vous et on vous aime
bien parce que vous faites pas de vague
mais c'est à dire c'est que on vous aime
bien parce que vous effacer votre
identité et dès que les personnes
commencent à parler à s'imposer à dire
non moi je suis dacc deuxième génération
je suis française et je veux pas être
envoyé à mon faciès est bien là ça ça
dérange un petit peu plus d'honnêteté
des lacs pour terminer oui vous avez
raison il ya aussi et à la perception du
fait que les communautés asiatiques en
france mais s'en sort très bien les
gosses son premier à l'école des
implantations de commerces se sont
multipliées on parlait de belleville
tout d'ailleurs ça s'effrite est un peu
avec les robots non parce que petit à
petit des commerciaux chinois prenait la
place de commerce qui étaient tenus par
des maghrébins 10 sont perçues comme un
peu on sait déjà avant la guerre qui
disait les juifs iwuy finalement bon ils
ramassent le fric mais c'est parce
qu'ils sont plus intelligents que nous
by a un peu le même truc
les chinetoques bas ils sont malins et
petit à petit nom mais je j'essaie
d'analyser les seuils d'analyser les
décrit les choses les racisme et les
préjugés pas se raconter des histoires
de gens disent à tiques 1 95% ou pas au
sortir un peu du tout ce qui est marrant
10 manquent pas on avait envie d'en
parler sur ce plateau pour essayer de
voir pointer du doigt ces phénomènes
racistes qui on a compris dépasse cette
question de la crainte d'un virus merci
beaucoup va accueillir pour terminer
elsa monde un gars va c'est l'heure de
notre point retraite vous le savez comme
tous les jours bonsoir elza van soir le
point retraite pour une retraite à
points on le dit on le redit
l'obstruction des insoumis ralentit
considérablement l'examen du texte en
commission spéciale où en est-on ce soir
alors on en est en ce moment à l'article
7 donc delà du projet de loi pour la
réforme des retraites c'est celui qui
met fin aux régimes spéciaux à la sncf
et à la ratp
notamment on a voté aujourd'hui un
article crée ce fameux régime universel
et donc on y met toutes les professions
qui avaient des retraites un peu
particulière les travailleurs
indépendants les professions libérales
les agriculteurs les profs les policiers
les magistrats
oui mais sauf que toutes ces professions
et bien en train de négocier avec leur
ministère de tutelle pour avoir des
aménagements et donc ça donne des
discussions bilatérales en plus une
conférence de financement avec des
partenaires sociaux et donc des députés
de l'opposition qui ont l'impression de
passer à côté de l'essentiel écouter et
une troisième mi-temps il ya eu deux ans
de concertation il y a le débat
parlementaire
et puis il ya des choses qui sont
renvoyées à plus tard enfin la seule
démonstration vous êtes en train de
faire si vous n'êtes pas prêt on
n'explique jamais comment on bouche les
trous
je crois que monsieur vélo a posé le
même type de questions on n'explique
jamais comment on bouche les trous ya
bien un moment donné il faudra les
bouchers parce qu'on n'est pas dans un
monde idéal on est dans un monde où un
moment donné il faut financer ce qu'on
décide de faire ce que nous sommes en
train de faire personne ne l'a fait de
mettre l'ensemble de nos concitoyens
dans le même régime
donc c'est un chantier c'est un chantier
d'ampleur sur lequel évidemment comme je
le dis à chaque fois il va falloir
recalé en permanence il va falloir
affiner les trajectoires
voilà des explications du rapporteur qui
ne convainquent pas vraiment les
oppositions je vous rappelle que les
insoumis eux ils ont déposé des
amendements ils veulent supprimer chaque
alinéa du texte il continue donc à
défendre leur position les débats vont
durer très certainement jusqu'à la
semaine prochaine c'est une course
contre la montre les retraites vous y
comprenez quelque chose ça vous
intéresse non non je bats le principe
est louable mais après ça a l'air
tellement compliqué que en tout cas on
essaye à faire un peu de pédagogie si
sûr et c'était merci beaucoup de nos
collègues d'être passés nous voir dans
cette émission merci à toutes mes dames
c'est la fin de cette émission merci à
vous de nous avoir suivis et à demain
[Musique]